مع دخول الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد شهره
الرابع وتحقيق بعض المكاسب توجه كبير
الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين انتوني بلينكن
الى كييف في زياره غير معلنه حملن معه
اكثر من مليار دولار كمساعدات شاهدنا
تقدما جيدا في الهجوم المضاد وهو امر مشجع
للغايه نريد التاكد من ان اوكرانيا لديها
ما تحتاجه ليس فقط للنجاح في الهجوم
المضاد بل على المدى الطويل للتاكد من ان
لديها قدره دفاعيه قويه وذلك كي لا تتكرر
مثل هذه الاعتداءات في المستقبل للمره
الاولى منذ الغزوه الروسيه لاوكرانيا في
فبراير شباط عام 2022 سيقضي وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي ليلته في اوكرانيا حيث من المقرر
ان يلتقي بالرئيس بولو ميريز انسكي
ومسؤولين اخرين هذه الزياره جاءت بعد
ساعات على استهداف روسيا الموانئ
الاوكرانيه على نهر الدانوب وتناثر حطام
المسيرات على المناطق الرومانيه القريبه
وفق السلطات الاوكرانيه
واستنفار السلطات بوخارست العضو في حلف
شمال الاطلسيه
كما اخبرني وزير الدفاع تم التحقق من ان
الهجمات استهدفت المناطق على بعد 800 متر
من حدودنا وهي قريبه جدا جدا مع ذلك نحن
في حاله تاهب وحذر رومانيا مسلحه بشكل جيد
للغايه داخل حلف شمال الاطلسي مقابل الدعم
الامريكي الذي تخطط قيمته 43 مليار دولار
تواصل روسيا تكثيف غاراتها على المناطق
الاوكرانيه وموانئها الحيويه التي
تستخدمها منذ منعها من استخدام البحر
الاسود لتصدير الحبوب في تموز يوليو
الماضي كان اخرها استهداف المنشات
الزراعيه في منطقه اوديسا جنوبا وفقا حاكم
المدينه